hey what's going on everybody how's
everyone doing on this fine fine day my
name is cameron
and uh you're watching motion science
live live on tuesdays
uh what's going on everybody uh my name
is cameron if you don't know who i am
um i've been a motion designer for over
20 years
primarily primarily working in after
effects
and a little bit of cinema 4d i know
enough about cinema 4d to be dangerous
for 13 of those years i've been a i was
a remote freelancer before remote
freelancing was even a thing i've had
the opportunity to work for studios like
prologue and digital kitchen and clients
like 343 industries amazon
discovery disney mtv
rca records xbox sony and many many more
so
that's a little bit about me if you
don't know who i am if you're new
to the channel welcome
um i see a few familiar faces in chat
here
today we're talking about uh how to use
mood boards to gather information
and save time that's the most important
thing how to use mood boards to gather
information and
save time um but before i get into that
i want to hear from you
um i want to know what do you struggle
with the most uh when it comes to being
creative
what do you struggle with the most when
it comes to being creative is it coming
up with the idea
is it a client who says to you
hey use your imagination that's always a
great one
we trust you
or is it that you don't know where to
start
i want to know i want to hear from you
in the chat box
what do you struggle with the most
when it comes to being creative
what do you struggle with the most when
it comes to being creative
also while you're answering that in the
chat box
um i want to let you know that i do have
a free workshop over at
motionscience.tv that's motionscience.tv
uh where i show you seven secrets
uh to cinematic motion design these are
seven tips tricks and concepts
um behind
pro level motion design that i've
developed over the years and i show you
these seven tips and tricks and concepts
uh in a very short workshop
plus i give you access to a very special
offer
at the end that you will not find
anywhere else
and i guarantee
it's a great offer
so please check it out if you haven't
already done so over at motionscience.tv
plus i give you a free texture pack so
can't beat it
so let's look at the um
chat box here hey paul morgan what's
going on
fade to nada what's up
harsh hi harsh
hey moe murdock what's going on moe
moe i know from stylecraft mo's a fellow
stylecraft member
um what's good a lot of things are good
it's a great day
great great day
i'm happy to be here with you guys today
to talk um
about mood boards uh good times hey
what's going on good times hd
uh
hello harsh hello brian rimmel hey brian
rumbles that's another
common name who's also a starcraft
member
um okay
fade to nada says realizing what's in my
head yeah that's a common creative
struggle is getting
what we see in our head
onto the screen right like that is
that's a huge challenge right i think
that's
in my opinion that's probably the
hardest
struggle creatively how to get what you
see in your head
onto the screen so we're going to talk a
little bit about that today
um
hey jamal what's going on
uh mo narrowing down the ideas and
picking a direction okay
that's also
uh super important uh which relates to
mood boards um it also has to do with
creative constraints i have a video out
there mo about using creative
constraints it's super important
um hey 550 dan lewis another stylecraft
member
happy to have you here dan
um andrew says defining the concrete
steps to put in the storyboards to find
the concrete stuff to put in the stores
interesting okay that's definitely a
creative struggle for sure
i don't use a ton of storyboards in my
work
um because i feel like it limits me
and kind of like pins me into like okay
you have to follow this storyboard now
um now when i say storyboard it may be
different than what you're thinking of
uh to me
a storyboard is a laid out like boom
boom boom succession if this is how it
happens exactly right this is what
exactly what we see
i like to kind of work more off style
frame
design which can be laid out but there's
a little bit room for interpretation in
terms of
motion and things like that like the
style is there the look is there
um but the motion
is a little bit open-ended but that's a
that's a definite creative struggle for
sure
uh mo brian says much science is great
thank you so much
appreciate that brian
um
what else we got here
where to start yeah that's a good one
where to start like
yeah where do you start right maybe you
have a creative brief or you have
a little information but it's like where
do you start right so having a creative
brief
style frames that can help you
narrow in on where to start
good times hd trying to create original
work when everything has been made and
there is so much amazing insane work out
there comparing with others so i'm going
to tell you right now
you're wrong on two points good times hd
not everything has been made okay
everything has
okay i'll take so everything has been
made but it's your interpretation of how
to show that right so
you can go back thousands of years
everything's been done over and over
again it's the same story over again
rewritten a different way it's the same
visual redone a different way right
it's up to you to interpret it and put
it out there to the world as yours
the second point is don't compare
yourself to others i know it's really
challenging especially in today's world
of social media
it's real challenging not to compare
yourself but don't do it okay you are
unique in who you are and what your
unique abilities are so don't compare
yourself to other people
stay away from that
uh sim
sim
not being sure ideas that come up are
actually any good well that's a good
challenge too for sure
um
you never do know unless you just try it
right sometimes i'll have the greatest i
think it's the greatest idea
i do it i implement it and it sucks
you don't know unless you try right and
a lot of us get scared to even take that
first step but you have to
try but that's a great creative struggle
sim
uh alexander collecting all inspiring
references yeah
that has a lot to do with mood boards i
mean everything you guys are talking
about has to do with mood boards so it's
these are great
collecting a lot of inspirational
references is key
um ethan struggle with getting stuck in
the startup process getting bogged down
with naming organizing and preparing
assets can slow down the creative fire
yeah
it is important there has to be a good
balance there right like you don't want
to get so tied up that everything has to
be
perfectly laid out um but i'll tell you
ethan a great way to start is
and i talk about this in after effects
academy volume 1.
i also think i have a quick tip video
out there somewhere on youtube
where if you create a
project
[Music]
you can tell after effects basically in
your preferences to open up a specific
project every time you open up
after effects and create a new project
if you have a folder structure already
built inside of after effects it's
really important to have a folder
structure it's very laid out
when you start
jamming and you start bringing in assets
and starting to get creative
um
i like to just jam and bring things in
and just drag and drop put in the
folders maybe even not putting the
floors just put it in there and then
start
jamming on my designs my motion and then
start dragging and dropping so things
can stay somewhat organized
but i really feel like it's important
that you just start jamming at first and
don't get caught up in
being super
organized okay it is important to name
things properly especially if you're
passing off files to other designers
there's nothing worse than getting a
horrible project file but that doesn't
mean that you can't start designing
animating and getting further down the
road and then coming in and kind of
cleaning things up right that's how i
kind of work
uh anda you haven't missed
just a bunch of questions so far
glad to have you here um let's see
damn brain to screen motion so to speak
is the hardest for me
from a technical point of view like how
do i get this thing to move exploded
like i see in my head that's a great
creative struggle dan
which again comes back to mood boards
right and having reference creative
reference creative inspiration creative
reference
so we'll talk about that
and see good times hd
is there a platform to share work and
get feedback apart from starcraft do you
do personal review on reels just
wondering things for the probably um i
do
um through a something new that's coming
out
but you have to be a member of
stylecraft to get access to it
so
it's called the stylecraft accelerator
and it's where i
[Music]
work with small groups one-on-one
every week and i review your work
and
really help you fine-tune your work and
help you understand what your struggles
are and how we can kind of push past
those struggles really quickly
and get better so yeah it's called the
stylecraft accelerator
but you have to become a member of
stylecraft to get it
and it's coming very soon
hey devicks good to have you here
um
okay so and i see another question but
i'm gonna just jump in here and start
talking about um
start talking about
um
mood boards right
let me clear a few things off here
so i can see things for me
there we go
so i don't know how many of you guys
know what mood boards are
get rid of that there we go
but essentially mood boards are like a
great
place to put a lot of inspiration and
you do it kind of like an organized
categorical way
so that you can come back and reference
this inspiration at any time
now before you can build a mood board
you have to
have inspiration right to put in your
mood board now three sites i have three
sites that i always go to for creative
inspiration
um
not in any particular order
but the first is pinterest
um i love pinterest
because
there's so much there to see right
there's so much that we can um let me
actually pull this up here
as i switch my screen
so pinterest right so i love pinterest
because there's just so much here right
and pinterest just keeps growing and
growing growing so like
my favorite thing to do in pinterest is
just come to a pinterest page and just
type in a simple search like motion
design like we see here right there's a
lot of different categories that will
pop up
and we can go into these in more detail
um we can keep it more broad and kind of
search you know just kind of like skim
across things i love to be on pinterest
every week uh just looking for
inspiration now maybe i'll see something
that inspires me to go even deeper down
a rabbit hole of like what that is
um and maybe i won't it's funny there's
there's a motion science pen right there
under motion design
so maybe like i'll look at
and it doesn't have to be motion design
right i also like to look at things like
let's do grunge
aesthetic
and let it load up and you know there's
things here that have nothing to do with
motion design like clothing right
clothing magazines
um
here's some type of social media post
when i find something here
that really like calls to me i'll save
it to a board right so and we'll talk
about boards in here in just a second
but that is
pinterest right there's so many
different ways you can search things
you don't want to limit it to just
motion design you want to even like
architecture right architecture's super
inspirational writing magazines
clothing whatever it may be
the next place i love to look at is
behance
um
behance
again so much creative inspiration here
we can go down different rabbit holes
and
you know search for specific things like
if i see like this is a guy tauros i
love
his uh design
um
i actually follow tauros
so that i get notified when new projects
come out
but you know so much great inspiration
here and what like for example if i pull
up tauros here
i think it was dan lewis 550 uk that was
asking like how do you execute something
if i find something that really
is inspiring to me
you know i don't just save this to a
mood board i i actually will
study it i'll look at it if there's an
animation piece
i'll really study it almost frame by
frame sometimes
to to try and understand okay how did
they pull this off was this 3d was this
2d was it two and a half d is it a
particle system
um how would i pull it off you know i
like to think a lot about pieces when i
find them that are inspirational to me i
don't just
see and go oh that's cool save and and
move on you know i i just really try and
break it down and and discover like what
how could they have pulled this off
um you know to me the best way to do
that is with an animation piece
this one doesn't have any animation
but just going frame by frame and just
studying it
right sometimes you'll even see like a
little breakdown
of how they created this spot
um so like here i am just going to hold
down shift with my arrow key
and go on you know frame by frame and uh
like this i i love this particular
frame here this composition
well i've i've seen enough of long
shadows
uh tutorials and things like that i
could pull this off pretty i could do
this all in after effects right i don't
need cinema 4d to do this
but then a lot of times too all if i
have the time i may just go in and just
experiment open up after effects and
just experiment and see
how close can i get to this like maybe
i'll take a screenshot of this
shift command 4 i'll take a screenshot
and i'll open up after effects i'll
bring this screenshot in as reference
plop it in there in the composition up
in the top left corner
and just see how close i can get to this
you know i love the colors i love the
lights and the shadows
i love the extruded text and how it's
connected to that back wall right these
are all things about it that i love and
i'm trying to understand what is it
about this image that's so cool
and that's what i kind of break down in
my head and if i have time i take the
prac i put it into practice
uh third place
instagram um this is a little bit better
if it's you know on your phone it looks
a little nicer versus a web browser um
but i follow
not even that many people i think i
follow maybe 150 people
something like that um i'm pretty picky
about who i follow i do file follow um
different people who come into motion
science that i
make a connection with and we talk a lot
and i'll follow them or i'll follow
someone who
is very inspirational to me if i come
across their work
and just follow them and when i see
things i like
i save it to my mood board right
so these are three places that i love to
go to uh for inspiration now it doesn't
mean that these are the only places that
exist for inspiration um these are just
the places that i um
personally love
now
let me pull my notes back up here really
quickly um what i love to do on these
three different sites is i love to
collect still images
i love to collect videos and i love to
collect gifs anything that's in motion
right
it's very easy to do this uh in
pinterest and behance it's a little more
time consuming to do this in instagram
but i'll show you what i do uh for
instagram
again i don't just focus on
motion design collections
i
look for ideas that inspire me
imagery that inspires me that could be
from the typography and again i go back
to okay something caught my eye with
this image or this piece of motion
what is it is it the color is it the
type
um is it the motion
is it um a principle of design is it
like something like contrast
um is it atmosphere
is it
you know what is it i don't
dive in immediately and start trying to
figure out technically how they did it
at first i tried to dissect what about
this piece do i love because
i may love the type but i may hate the
color
right
um i may
love the motion but hate the design
so i want to just i want to save these
different pieces of imagery
and then i want to look at them and
study them and understand
what about them am i drawn to and the
more you do this the quicker you will
get at this
and then lastly well then i add them to
a mood board and then lastly i
try to understand how they created it
because once i understand that
when it comes to a real world project
it's easier for me to implement that
and put it into my own work
so
i don't just look at motion design i
look at architecture magazines posters
art installations museums
newspapers whatever it is that inspires
me and it's type it's colored shape it's
motion whatever it is
i am looking for inspiration
once i find
that inspiration that's when i start to
build a mood board and i'll go back here
and i'll show you we'll start here and
be hands so
um in behance you can create you get
behance with um any adobe cc
subscription at least that's my
understanding
it's free
and it's great just to
it allows you to create mood boards so
you can see right here mood boards is
one of the default
categories within your behance profile
and
i just start adding
pieces to different mood boards now the
mood boards that you're seeing here um
have a lot to do with stylecraft so if
you've taken the stylecraft course
what we do is we go into these mood
boards like line
and i
dissect
what about these pieces
you know or calling to me like i was
just talking about but before i get to
that point i'm just whenever i'm finding
if i'm searching for something about
line maybe i'm searching up here for
line i'm finding something i like i
immediately add it to my mood board
and it's really easy to do that all you
do when you see the image
you can appreciate that project and you
can save
that project you can add it to a mood
board and it pulls up your mood boards
here
and you just pick the collection you
want to add it to or you create a new
mood board
and add it right there
so super simple uh process to create
mood boards and add new imagery to mood
boards here
just it gets a little bit funky once
you're within a mood board um getting
back to your mood board see it creates a
new tab here
which is kind of weird
but
the more mood boards i have right the
more mood boards i have the more
inspiration i have
the easier it is for me to when a client
comes to me and says
we just don't know what we want right
well number one that's a lie because a
client always has some idea of what they
want
right they saw something somewhere
that said we need to make a motion
graphics piece a motion design piece
and do something like that now they may
not tell you that right up front but
they saw something at some point
that inspired them to to create
something they don't no clients ever
going to come to you and be like i have
no idea what motion graphics are i think
i should create something what do you
think right if that's the client i would
say
figure it out and come back and see me
later or i'd fire the client
but anyways the more boards you have
the more inspiration you have to pull
from so
sometimes from a client you'll get a
creative brief
that will list certain things that
they're looking for um
that can help to like let's say they're
you know they're really interested in a
certain type of typography i can open up
my typography board and kind of dive in
here and look and see hey does something
in here kind of relate to what they're
looking for the client's looking for if
they have no idea
i'm going to be pulling up these mood
boards to get inspiration for myself
to start trying things
right so um this is how i kind of use
behance um
also within pinterest here
um pinterest is more
like my go-to
mood board
you know central location i've been
using pinterest for a longer amount of
time
and i've created more mood boards here
now some of them are private and if you
don't follow motion science on behance
or pinterest
i highly advise that you go check it out
um
lots of great inspiration for you right
and you can come here you can check out
my mood boards
feel free to save them to your own mood
boards
you can follow different boards
i always try and add
new material to these boards so they're
always growing some of them grow faster
than others just depends on what i'm
working on
so again let's go find here here's my
typography board and you can see it's
typography and it's got 202 pens
right because i've been building this
one longer so when i open it up
excuse me um there's a lot of type here
right a lot of type for reference like
where you know
i've got the in all depends on what your
project is that you're being tasked with
to what you know i should be using for
typography so
um i have a kind of a moodier darker
style
so a client's going to probably come to
me to create something
moody and and dark now if a corporate
client comes to me and says you know we
need really clean type and
and it's got to be super corporate you
know there's nothing wrong with that but
i'm not going to come to this typography
board here and probably pull something
from that you know from this board for
that project because they just don't
they don't gel they don't
match uh what your clients looking for
so
this is stuff that i just find highly
inspirational
um
that i can pull from whenever i'm in a
project
and there's so many different ways
you know different directions you can go
with this type
so as you can see here
lots and lots of boards a lot of times
i'll find that my my
mood boards will actually
um like this one right here sex drugs
and rock and roll
this
i just saw this particular pen on
another
mood board i was looking at just a
couple days ago so a lot of them i find
that i save
on multiple boards and when i start to
see that
it also tells me like hey this is
something that you keep coming across
it's an imagery it's imagery you keep
coming across that is highly
inspirational to you
and you might want to pay more attention
to it you might want to give it a little
bit more attention because you keep
coming back to it for different reasons
like this
you know this one's in my typography
board but it also might be in my
contrast board
because there's a lot of contrast in
this piece so it just really depends so
just really pay attention to those types
of
images that keep popping up over and
over again
i also create just random
boards just because like album covers
right like i'm never i've never been
tasked with creating an album cover um
but i still find them inspirational and
i like to keep
album covers i guess kind of classified
in album covers right like this image
here of nin at a concert this is
obviously not an album cover
but i love nine inch nails as you can
see
and for whatever reason i feel like this
was probably a great place to put it
but again
music album covers are highly
inspirational to me um i can pull a lot
from these for example this one badlands
house halsey
i love the type that it's simple and
clean i love the color palette the blues
and the pinks and the browns i also love
the texture right so
there's three things right there
that i really dig i also kind of like
this contrast between her and this stone
behind her
so that one mood board is inspiring me
in four different ways
uh let's go back here let's look at more
what else we have here we've got
uh like cyberpunk right it's only got
two pens in it that's okay right like
there's i do think i have some other
boards that are more retro like and
maybe i could combine
uh at least this one into those this
one's a little more
uh it's not retro right it is very
cyberpunk kind of futuristic love the
texture love the type treatment
highly inspirational
let's go back here and look
um
shape digital texture film frames again
this board is
the sole purpose of this board
is for
um
assets for me to use
to kind of frame my compositions right
like maybe i want to use um
this strip here
maybe i want to pull this strip here and
kind of lay it in the left side of my
composition and that's all this is
referenced for
whereas maybe this one right here
excuse me is more about
an overlay of like color and texture
and i love the red and the blue and i
love that kind of gritty
uh grit that we see in there here's
another great one right here all right i
love that a lot too i'm actually going
to go ahead and just save it
really nice and that's another great
thing about pinterest is that it just
gives you more and more reference like
hey you like these images we think you
might also like these
and you can quickly just keep adding to
your boards
um over and over again
um so anyways whenever i'm starting a
project um i'm gonna come here to
pinterest or behance and i'm going to
reference it now let me show you really
quickly what i do with instagram um if
i'm in instagram what i do is i actually
pull up
um something that inspires me and i
either take a screenshot of it or i
screen capture it with my iphone um i
don't on the android i don't know how
that works
but on the iphone it's really easy to
screen capture
footage or just take a screenshot and
what i do then is i create different
folders within my photo album like this
one's called motion science it's more of
a generalized
folder that i have different imagery
here this is actually an older one
you'll see people who are in stylecraft
may see some things here that inspire
you for for some of the stylecraft
lessons you can see where i was pulling
inspiration from
some of them are doubled up for some
reason i noticed but um
i just put them into a folder structure
within my photos and then on a mac i'm
able to open up this application called
photos and i can see everything in one
location i can create as many folders
structures as i want and i can drag and
drop and you know maybe i put like some
screen graphics maybe i decide to put
these in a different folder or whatever
it is but this is a great way as well to
get inspiration from instagram some of
these are are motion some of them are
just you know straight up
screenshots and that's okay too
um
but that is how i capture imagery from
instagram and then create mood boards
within my photos
on the mac
switch this over really quickly here
but i'm going to tell you guys any time
i ever start a project
it doesn't matter if the client comes to
me with a big creative brief
and says
you know here's the typeface you're
going to use here's the colors
here's imagery reference i'm still going
to come back to my own mood boards
i'm going to pull imagery
from the mood boards and that's
something i didn't tell you guys but i
like to take all this different imagery
and i like to compile it
into like a photoshop document
or into canva canva's got a really cool
application within it
where you can import
all of your different imagery into canva
and you can just say hey lay this out in
the mood board and it takes all the
imagery and it just makes it look all
nice and pretty and lays it out then i'm
going to give that to the client i'm
going to say here's what i'm thinking
what do you think here's my
mood board for typography i'm going to
give them several references for
typography
or here's my mood board for color
and it has several color references i'm
going to put these mood boards together
based on the mood boards i've already
created i'm going to pull imagery
together
what has inspired me based on that
project
and i'm going to send those to the
client and say
what do you think
do you like the color the way that where
i'm moving with the color do you like
where i'm moving with the typography
here's some of the imagery i'm thinking
about using things like that and it
helps you get on the same page with your
client it helps them to understand kind
of what you're thinking in your head
maybe they're going to send you a mood
board and you're going to add to that
mood board or take away from that mood
board so
mood boards are just an awesome awesome
way
to help you overcome a lot of your
creative struggles
and save time with with moving forward
in the creative process because once you
guys have decided your client and you
have decided or even you personally if
it's your own project if you decided
okay here's what's in my mood board
now i'm going to move forward with the
next step which is maybe designing
something out or maybe you don't have
time to design or there's no budget and
you have to jump right into the project
you still have a lot of reference from
those mood boards of where
where you need to move what direction
you need to move in
a lot of times as well i'll bring in a
mood board into after effects i'll bring
it in as a as a single png or a pdf
and i'll just place it up there in the
corner of my composition
i'll lock that layer and i turn it off
and on and that way i always have
reference there on my screen
to
help me in the design or motion process
there's also an application called
pureref
that i used to use it used to be free i
don't know if it's free anymore or not
but it's a great little application
where it keeps everything that you're
referencing for your mood boards on your
screen at all times so it's always there
so again
there's so much power in mood boards i
start most of my project with a mood
board
if time allows
um
go back to some of your questions here
uh jason says you normally present mood
boards to clients or
uh is it more just for your own
reference it really just depends jason
if a client if i'm working with a client
who um you know should respect what i'm
doing yes i'm going to give them a mood
board
and allow them to see that mood board
and kind of walk them through what i'm
thinking
and again i'm breaking down mood boards
into
things that they can easily understand
like i'll call one mood board typography
and one mood board is color and one mood
board's atmosphere and one mood board is
whatever just depending on the project
right maybe there's just more
generalized references for projects that
you
have um seen
that you could kind of take a lot of
creative reference from and kind of put
your own twist on it for this particular
client but yeah i will share mood boards
for sure
with my client
uh anda said how long do you test and
try an idea to see if it works i have
ideas that seem to work but i start
executing them i see they suck and i
have to start from scratch
it really depends again is it a personal
project for for myself or is it for a
client if it's for a client i don't ever
spend more than a day
working on something um if we're just in
that creative process of like trying to
figure out the overall look and feel of
something
um
i don't know i never spend more than a
day on something maybe a day and a half
and then send it off
and get feedback immediately
before i move forward with anything else
just to make sure that hey this is going
to work or it's not going to work
it also helps me to understand like
you know where am i going with this
project is it going to work can i pull
this off
or do i need to step back and kind of
rethink some things
other projects with bigger budgets that
i've worked on have allowed
sometimes two or three weeks of r d
where we're just um
experimenting
with different motion techniques or
design
to get some
to kind of get some things we're really
proud of that we're happy with
that we then show a client uh to get
feedback on and these are like you know
bigger budget projects like for like
xbox and things like that a lot of times
we'd get weeks
um with a team
just doing r d and experimenting and
designing and things like that so
it just depends on your budget if it's a
personal project again i wouldn't spend
more than a day today and a half
seeing if something works or not i mean
the most frustrating process is
when you try something it doesn't work
you try again it doesn't work you try
again it doesn't work i've had some of
those jobs before
um and then you kind of just have to
settle at some point and say okay enough
is enough we need to move forward
this is going to be the best direction
moving forward and let's let's take it
let's run with it you know because not
every project is going to be amazing
right like
i don't ever want to deliver a project
that
i'm not proud of but that doesn't mean
that it has to be the best product
you've ever created of course as an
artist we always strive to create the
best we can
but it's okay
not to have the most amazing piece
and just to put something out there that
you're like hey you know
for what this is it's still good it's
still
maybe there's a couple of
moments that are really awesome and some
that aren't so great but you know
i can't always be the best
uh jl what are your favorite sites to
get reference images
um
uh instagram
pinterest
behance
those are my top three
um
i mean those are pretty much the three i
always go to i have enough imagery in my
mood boards now between behance and
pinterest
that i don't have to go out and search
for a ton of new imagery all the time
and my mood boards you know will
recommend certain imagery to me because
i have a certain style right now when i
was a freelancer
i was known as more of a generalist
and
that meant that i had a unique style but
i could also do a lot of other styles
which was you know i was very thankful i
was able to do that
but
typically when a client's coming to me
they know i have a certain style
they kind of want that style
uh in some capacity and so
my imagery is there
within my own mood boards to easily and
quickly pull from
so yeah instagram pinterest behance
patrick what type of media do you tend
to use for mood boards still photos
movie clips animations or ads
it's a mix it's a mix most of them are
still images images
but i if i can get
something in motion i will take it
because like i said i like to dissect
frame by frame
what that piece is about
um
so
you know it just depends like that's one
thing with pinterest is that it always
links to an outside like youtube or
vimeo which is kind of annoying to me
that you can't just have it sometimes
you'll find them embedded within
pinterest a lot of times just leave
pinterest to go watch whatever it is
which is a little bit annoying
um so most of the time it's it's still
imagery
gifs if i can
jail i have a hard time coming up with
keywords yeah i get it
um if you get a creative brief from your
client
um a lot of times they'll have keywords
in that creative brief or they'll write
out
basic overviews that you can pull
keywords from that overview if you don't
get a creative brief
um it's
up to you to create your own creative
brief
and create keywords
based on that creative brief um i have a
mini workshop a mini course
over at motionscience.tv it's only 47
bucks and it um
teaches you how to create your own
um
creative brief for your own work i think
it's up if it's not up somebody hit me
up and let me know but i think it's up
there
but it's it's super powerful that you
underst if you understand how to create
your own creative brief if there's not
one for you it's very very powerful
it'll help you come up with your own
keywords
if i can't come up with keywords for
some reason
a lot of times i'll just start kind of
basic like motion design or motion
design
mood or moody or dark and moody or title
design and i'll start listing images and
you know start giving me ideas for other
keywords and i'll actually end up
opening up multiple tabs across
my safari sometimes i'll have tons of
tabs open
because i'm doing all these different
searches right based on different
keywords so
there's no right or wrong answer to a
keyword
and the more you do this
the more you'll start to understand what
certain keywords
are valuable and which ones aren't
uh 550 you mentioned using images from
pinterest in your motion as you are only
using a portion of it as an overlay is
that okay from a copyright point of view
i heard you have to change a percentage
yeah i actually don't i should take that
back when i was talking about the film
edges i don't use those actual images
um
for the most part
um that are on pinterest like the film
frames maybe but yes you do need to
change it
and if i'm gonna use something like a
film frame from pinterest most of the
time i find that they're not high res
enough to begin with
so i've actually built my own collection
of film frames
to use but if it is high res enough
i'm going to do a lot of compositing and
transfer modes and things like that
within after effects on that film frame
to the point where it's not even going
to be recognizable as to where it came
from to begin
so yes i'm changing a huge percentage of
it i don't know what that percentage is
but i would never just take an image
and copy paste into my own work you're
gonna get into trouble
uh silvic can you draw i heard that if
you want to be good in animation you
have to be good at drawing is that right
no
i cannot draw
uh if you ever watch my story
on youtube i talk about i've never taken
an art class in my life
i can't draw i can't even draw a stick
figure i mean i'm terrible i can barely
draw on the computer like if i was going
to illustrator
but i teach a way of creating design
which is more like i call it like
there's different names for it like
photo bashing and and things like that
where i take lots of different elements
from different sources and i kind of
bash them together into a design but no
i can't draw you do not have to know how
to draw
um
to be an animator to be a designer
no
uh
what do you think of fusion in davinci
resolve i use dr for color grading but
fusion boggles the mind more than ae i
don't i don't use it i don't know enough
about it i don't i mean i use after
effects for everything
including color grading so
um
my buddy ryan
uses fusion um
absolutely loves it for color grading
he's got some some lessons on that
within motion science some bonus lessons
i think it's a color one or color two
workshop
uh but i don't know enough about it
after effects is all i need
uh hey dale what's going on think pixels
good to hear from you man
i faded nana nada if you nana i don't
know why i keep saying nana i guess i
keep thinking about my mom her name's
nana
if you have to buy a computer today for
after effects on a limited budget what
would you get i would get an apple
computer
hands down i would not buy a pc
i've always been an apple fan
and yes they're more expensive but they
also hold their value
um they hold their value for years and
years and years and years
the most important thing to get is a
high is a really fast cpu
and as much ram as you can get in that
machine
you don't need a fancy graphics card
uh the ondonga adango i just want to
appreciate your channel gain some skills
here which i really needed to what i had
awesome
thank you
i appreciate that
yeah dale you missed some of my lives
that's okay
uh so guys that is gonna do it for this
live actually so dale you got here at
the end but i advise you just to go back
and watch
um
talked about mood boards and how
important they are mood boards are life
they are life and motion design like if
you don't have a mood board
you need to start some mood boards right
away start making them
it's super important for you just to
have that creative reference that
creative inspiration that you can always
pull from guys i mean i i started making
mood boards years ago
and
the more mood boards you have the more
inspiration you have the faster you're
gonna get at
your work and the quicker you're going
to get you know in your creative
response to clients and to yourself and
it's just going to get
so much better for you so
thanks everyone for being here today i
really appreciate all of your comments
and your questions and you guys are just
awesome and i love showing up and
and talking to you guys and uh i'm not
sure if i'll be here next week or not
i'm going to try really hard like i said
i'm not going to do this every tuesday
i'm going to do as many tuesdays as i
can and so i'm going to try really hard
to be here next tuesday i'm traveling
but i think i should be back just in
time to do a live
uh so you guys just keep on rocking it
keep on creating
and uh i'll talk to you guys all very
very soon
see ya